the boys are back today we're talking
about sam and bucky aka marvel studios
the falcon and the winter soldier i'm
andre and i'm jenny this is what's up
disney plus where we talk all things
disney plus
the rain sink is a senior creative
producer and host of the marvel
entertainment youtube channel and we are
very thrilled to have her here with us
today lorraine welcome to what's up
disney plus hey jenny andre i'm so
excited to find out what's up we're glad
to have you here we know that you are a
huge marvel fan so how did you get into
that well like a lot of kids i learned
to read by reading comics and i just
fell in love with superheroes and it's
become a lifelong passion and now i've
worked for marvel for 10 years written
three books and hosted a whole lot of
red carpets that's amazing all right
lorraine we thought who better to help
us catch up for marvel studios the
falcon and the winter soldier than
yourself oh yeah on your left let's do
it well i'm glad you're ready because a
lot has happened to these two characters
throughout the course of the marvel
cinematic universe we want to catch
everybody up but lorraine we like to
challenge ourselves here on what's a
busy plus so we're gonna try to recap it
in record time are you ready yes i am
ready i am channeling all my super speed
alright then let's do it
in the marvel cinematic universe bucky
first appears as steve rogers bestie
from brooklyn james buchanan barnes or
bucky for short bucky went off to fight
in world war ii where he reconnected
with steve now as captain america while
they tried to take down a hydra base in
austria while kepp is victorious bucky
is thrown off a train and thought to be
dead fast forward years later when sam
and kat become close as fellow veterans
who lost a best friend in the line of
duty so when shield is infiltrated by
hydra sam gives cap and black widow a
place to lay low which gets even more
complicated when an assassin starts
hunting them named the winter soldier
when he and cap finally come face to
face he is revealed to be
bucky that's right he's alive but his
memory has been wiped and modified by
hydra cap black widow and sam battle the
winter soldier but steve doesn't have
the heart to take out his best friend an
unconscious cap falls to the water below
and bucky regaining a fragment of his
former self dives in to save steve then
after he leaves him on the shore and
disappears during marvel studios age of
ultron bucky is nowhere to be seen but
sam does get an upgrade including a
heroic costume when the avengers expand
their ranks after the battle of sokovia
at the resulting sokovia courts a bomb
is detonated seemingly by bucky barnes
which kills the wakandan king t'chaka
and his son t'challa pledges to kill
bucky himself captain america and sam
wilson head out to bring in bucky
however it turns out bucky was framed
bucky now in winter soldier mode beats
sam and escapes cap stops bucky and
saves his life like bucky once did for
him so when sam and bucky are reunited
on the same team sam is not a huge fan
of bucky who tried to assassinate all of
his best friends during the epic
showdown team cap and team iron man face
off and bucky and sam managed to work
together despite bickering like an old
married couple i hate you zevo is
revealed to be the bomber clearing
bucky's name and team cap goes after him
ultimately cap seeks asylum in wakanda
where bucky is put on ice to remove his
hydra programming poor sam wilson
unfortunately is locked up at the raft
with the other avengers in marvel
studios avengers infinity war we see sam
has been released and allowed to rejoin
the avengers who take on thanos bucky
and sam reunite back in wakanda battling
the children of thanos and their army of
outriders then in a snap they're gone
and we won't see them again on anyone's
left until they're brought back later
through doctor strange's magic portals
in the epic final battle of marvel
studios avengers in game i love that
part after all the dust clears a much
older captain america is revealed to
have used the quantum suit to go back in
time and return all of the infinity
stones bucky looks on as captain america
passes the shield to sam
[Music]
[Applause]
what a journey that those two characters
have been on what a journey we just went
through trying to recap all of it before
you go lorraine can you tell us what we
can expect coming up on the marvel
entertainment youtube channel yeah you
can check out everything in the marvel
universe we're gonna have some cool
stuff i'm sure coming up for marvel
studios the falcon and the winter
soldier then also go back and check out
some of the cool stuff we created around
marvel studios one division i mean it's
all there just go go check it out well
thank you so much lorraine for recapping
this as quickly as possible with andre
and i we can't thank you enough you are
awesome oh my gosh you guys are awesome
you did so well with all of that marvel
universe because it is a lot let me tell
you thank you so much for having me and
now here's what's new
break the fourth wall of marvel studios
one division with marvel studios
assembled the making of one division an
original special now streaming on disney
plus this april come back down to earth
earth moods an original series from
national geographic is streaming april
16th on disney plus in collaboration
with first book disney is celebrating
the magic of storytelling by helping to
cultivate the next generation of
storytellers and providing books to
educators who serve kids in need hear
from some of your favorite disney plus
stars and learn more at
magicofstorytelling.com
now we get to hear from anthony mackie
and sebastian stan take a look
i'm sebastian stan and i'm anthony
macking we are the stars of marvel
studios the falcon and the winter
soldier we are gonna have a compliment
showdown where do we start sebastian you
have wonderful hair okay well you have
such a big heart that's protected by a
lot of strength sebastian your
personality would make a grown man smile
the walls that you have will protect me
forever
you make me so happy i want to sit in
your lap and cuddle no couch will ever
be as firm and soft as your thighs
you're like
the goose down of beautiful people
you're warm and inviting i will always
walk into your shadow if i have to
i'll be the man who will fight for your
honor we don't need any other heroes but
you
there's no way on earth that we could
wake up and it not be a sunny day
without thinking of the face of
sebastian stan
i want to remake every romantic comedy
with you
you my friend are the scrambled eggs to
my omelet oh my god
i think i won we were great stream
marvel studios the falconer and the
winter soldier tomorrow on disney plus
we heard from lorraine sink and the cast
of marvel studios the falcon and the
winter soldier i don't know about you
andre but i'm ready for action right
there with you jenny well that's it for
today make sure you go over to disney
plus to stream all of your favorites and
we'll see you next week all right andre
staring contest three two one go
and i blinked
[Music]
[Laughter]
just blank
[Music]
you